how do we adapt how do we what do we do
how do we how do we change the you know
system that was designed in the in the
18th century are you helping move things
forward by your personal behavior do you
believe that we really are the most
powerful nation normal what will the
world be like in 10 million years have
you ever come close to death if you're a
father and a husband are you as good as
you could possibly be one day my
daughter my second daughter said to me
Dad no one ever wished that their
tombstones said I wish I'd spent another
day at the office do you know the
circumstances of your birth have you
ever been accused of something that you
didn't do and by part of the problem or
I part of the solution what makes me
smile but happiness but what is it what
is it I want to know what will the first
people who encounter intelligent life
elsewhere think that's what the human
spirit is about asking questions why
can't we become civilized and you know
we were intelligent people which we
should become civilized
you